ben je vous remercie d'être venu pour
mon anniversaire j'ai 30 ans je sais ça
ne se voit pas mais je suis né il ya
trente ans le 30 ans j'étais très mince
très barbu je venais de passer 6 128
jours selon vous de deux mètres de
chaîne ce qui est court ma libération
c'est une seconde naissance
trente ans c'est le bel âge c'est au
moins le temps qu'il faut c'est l'âge
qu'il faut avoir pour commencer à
raconter une histoire qui a du mal à
vouloir se dire j'avais compris je vais
vous parler de liberté ou d'absence de
liberté j'ai cette chance là il ya
toujours moyen de poser de négocier ou
de renégocier les limites de sa liberté
et de sa dignité
la déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme 10 stipule bien que les hommes
naissent libres et égaux en droits et en
dignité
cela veut dire que l'homme ne peut
traiter l'homme se dire lui-même ou un
autre comme étant moyens mais comme une
fin
c'est précisément cela que consiste sa
dignité c'est notre identité même c'est
notre adn
ça ne ce n'est pas négociable en fait
j'aimerais vous parler de dignité
depuis que l'homme s'est mis debout
s'est inscrit dans une longue quête de
dignité
le la libération de la libération de
nelson mandela par exemple à la fin de l
esclavage que de combats à mener
là le vote des femmes la parité
hommes-femmes la fin du travail pour les
enfants de 12 ans dans les mines sont
autant de petits cailloux blancs dans
son autre chemin la démocratie est quand
même ce que nous avons inventé de mieux
pour vivre ensemble n'est ce pas elle
est la garante de notre de notre liberté
la liberté en démocratie évidemment
c'est plus facile mais je vous le redis
il ya toujours moyen de poser de
négocier ou de renégocier les limites de
sa liberté et de sa dignité comme
reporter j'ai couvert
j'ai connu beaucoup de pays en guerre le
rwanda le kosovo la somalie la bosnie le
liban bien sûr des pays en guerre où la
seule loi qui chez fois c'est la loi du
plus fort la loi du du mieux armé quand
j'étais arrêté à beyrouth 8 mars 1986 il
y avait pas
paniqué dans un premier temps c'était
juste un contrôle de routine par exemple
cela pouvait être c'était l'expression
de la loi du plus fort ni milice qui
montre ses muscles qui nous intercepte
avec mes confrères mais on n'est jamais
à l'abri du pire
au bout de quelques jours
j'étais dans une pièce close et aveugle
un groupe de type armé et cagoulé
rentrer dans la pièce avec un paquet de
chaîne dans les bras
c'est là où mes yeux devaient
ressemblent à des points d'interrogation
c'est le moment de l'incrédulité moment
de la stupeur c'est le moment où tout
bascule en fait c'est le moment où
l'homme - libre devient un moyen et non
une fin comme le dit la déclaration des
droits de l'homme
j'étais devenue un otage un otage
politique
je vais donc vous parler d'absence de
liberté
c'est là où en fait j'ai c'était
vraiment j'ai vécu le l'arbitraire le
plus absolu dans la privation de liberté
mais penser aller toujours vers un même
questionnement est ce que cette
situation me ramener à l'amour les
questions mon cerveau se frotter sans
cesse et toujours à quelques questions
comme quelle solution se suicider ce se
bat comme un dératé
regardez le tireur dans les yeux au
moment où au moment sentir et comprendre
quand elle est arrivée le dernier moment
et toutes ces considérations m'amener
systématiquement au moins un point de
rendez vous il fallait que je sois prêt
il fallait que je tente d'être digne
mais cadenas parce que j'avais des
canards avec la chaîne était détaché
trois fois par jour c'était le temps de
la promenade de la toilette et du repas
selon l'humeur du gard de s'était jamais
dans le même ordre
bien sûr et puis de temps en temps la
promenade ou le repas thé ap j'avais
essayé d'être honnête quand même parce
que faut que je vous dise tu avais clame
une vraie part d'humanité dans la
manière des tâches et les cannes selon
le moment il faut quand même comprendre
qu'à une marge entre avoir les deux
chevilles et les deux poignets attachés
chacun d'entre eux par un cadenas
ça fait 4 cadenas un jour et le
lendemain simplement les deux chevilles
attachées chacune d'entre elles par un
cadenas ces deux cas n'a de kannad
économiser c'est toujours ça bonjour oui
parce que c'est pas tout
ce fait trop facile non il ya vraiment
quelque chose de très pervers dans ce
genre de situation c'est pas une prison
ce genre de détention et un côté pervers
vous avez tous appris comme moi pourquoi
et comment les égorger de dèche n'ont
pas l'air trop stressée lors des vidéos
que je n'ai pas regardé en fait des
gelées prépare en faisant des simulacres
d'exécution ce qui fait que le jour de
l'exécution proprement dit les exilés
condamnés sont s'attendent pas à être
tué pour moi il y avait aussi un côté
comme cela
sympathique c'était une tentative une
volonté de me désinformées de me
déconnecter de la réalité
le peu de mots qui sortaient de derrière
les cagoules
c'était des mensonges donc père n'est
plus avec ta mère par exemple et me
montrer l'orient-le jour la couverture
de l'orient-le jour qui est le quotidien
libanais en langue française il y avait
une photo de mon père avec une dame
la femme de notre otage en fait serait
que le commentaire pervers appuyer là où
ça fait mal
savoir son propre père dans des routes
en guerre en train chercher son son
propre fils c'était douloureux vraiment
un jour j'étais debout ou deux mais de
mettre deux chaînes et en gare de
rentrer avec sa kalachnikov
il claque des doigts il me dit couchait
comme on le ferait un chien moyen le
héros que je ne suis pas très calmement
je dis non tout aussi calmement et je
venais de créer en fait sans le savoir
ce moment là le le plus fort des leviers
sur le chemin de ma résilience sur le
chemin de ma dignité sur le chemin de ma
survie aussi de ma survie pendant la
détention
[Musique]
c'est le moment en fait où j'ai pu
bouger les lignes dans mon rapport à
l'autre dans mon rapport aux gardes
d'ailleurs la manière dont ils m'ont
traitée après année la meilleure preuve
on n'allait pas croire que j'allais au
cinéma tous les soirs après cela mais
quand même il y avait une petite chose
qui changements acceptés mais pas
abandonner c'était mon mantra parce que
la liberté sus si l'on ne s'en sert pas
accepter c'est commencer à créer sa
liberté ne pas abandonner c'est
s'inscrire dans le temps parce qu'ils en
champ du possible au bout de 2 m de shon
homo nam n'aspire pas à la vie mortelle
mais épuisent le champ du possible c'est
pas de moi
cette peine d'art poètes grecs des mois
n'empêche que j'ai parlé à mon âme
pendant la guerre pendant ma détention
j'ai parlé à ma douleur je vais demander
à être calme et je dois reconnaître que
cette distanciation cet auteur avait une
vraie vertu thérapeutique
vous avez remarqué dans la vie on a
tendance à faire face tout le temps
tournait le dos ce maître de profil
la douleur l'accident a eu son vérité et
j'ai la faiblesse de penser qu'il faut
envisager le réel que avoir l'exigence
de faire face c'est commencer à gagner
en liberté
soyez le capitaine de votre âme disait
mandela dans mes rêves les plus fous
c'est interdit au bout de mètres de
mettre deux chaînes jeu j'avais les
bateaux les plus beaux les femmes les
plus douces je faisais les voyages les
plus magnifiques et alors surtout
j'avais une sensation incroyable jeu
pouvait voler je survolais les des
campagnes parfumées des paysages
magnifiques et rien ne pouvait m'arrêter
plus concrètement les déflagrations
alentours le tir les tirs des âmes des
armes automatiques les bruits monstrueux
des chenilles des blindés le stress des
gardiens me ramener à ce que j'étais à
ma condition fragile fragile suspendue
au bon vouloir des négociations
internationales au bon ou au mauvais
hasard vous devez vous dire dans la même
phrase celui-là il est resté attaché
trop longtemps parce que dans la même
phrase il nous parle du réel et de son
vol albatros bon d'accord c'est vrai je
suis resté attaché trop longtemps les
c'est dans ce temps que j'ai pu
construire un pont entre celui qui a les
pieds sur terre et la tête dans les
étoiles
celui qui accepte mais qui ne l'est pas
donc il n'abandonne pas ses voix c'est
cela être capitaine de sonam c'est
mettre du sens
la réponse oh ma réponse aux au gardien
est le fruit de cette quête de sens de
travail aussi personnelle du temps elle
est dite de la voix blanche de celui qui
traverse le désert de celui qui traverse
les peurs toutes les peurs de l'effroi à
celles qui restent collées dans la
bouche parce que la peur aussi un oui
évidemment
je dois vous dire les demandes de garde
car ma réponse il était sûr de lui armé
et cagoulé est un type enchaîné barbu
hirsute venait de lui dire non
il est sorti la pièce ton étalons il
était allé chercher ses supérieurs et
sont revenus plusieurs cagoulés armés
j'avoue que je n'en menais pas large se
sont assis en tailleur autour de moi et
en fait c'est là où tout bascule où tout
change parce que il ya une conversation
entre eux et moi presque civile presque
courtoise surréaliste et j'ai pu
prolonger la fermeté de ma posture avec
le garde en étant déterminé sur un point
non négociable
c'était ma dignité alors j'ai aussi le
la chance la présence d'esprit de savoir
lâcher du lest de dire bon les gars vous
voyez sur un otage modèle je fais pas de
crise de nerfs mais il ya une limite et
la limite c'est moi qui la pose là la
réflexion de l'homme qui n'est pas libre
est presque la même que celle de l'homme
libre et sa croche à 2 aspérités
l'espoir et la dignité parce que il ya
autre chose au delà de la vie au delà de
l'amour au-delà de la liberté et même il
ya la dignité la dignité de l'homme
notre statut d'être humain la dignité de
l'homme debout avec un grand h
parce qu'on peut être digne un étang
privé de liberté
je pense qu'on ne peut pas être libre
l'étang privé de liberté
diniz et pardon accepté mais pas
abandonnée je vous le redis c'est moi
qui pose la ligne c'est moi qui pose la
ligne merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]